okay so so i will talk about small value
parallel repetition and this is joint
work mark Berman so let's start with the
definition of to prove or one round
games so they're two provides Alice and
Bob and there is a verifier the verifier
gives Alice and Bob some x and y x and y
are distributed according to some joint
distribution mu and alice and bob are
required to answer with some a and B
which are functions of x and y 0
respectively and these X and this a and
B should satisfy some predicate v ok so
there's some predicate V on X a Y a and
B and they win the game if this
predicate is satisfied and we say so
value of the game is the maximum or
these strategies of Alice and Bob so
maximum over these functions a and B of
the probability of winning the game so
this probability is over the
distribution mu so this is the value of
the game and so these this predicate V
and distribution are part of the
definition of the game and there is
another parameter of interest which is
the answer length which is the number of
bits in a plus the number of bits in be
so we will cut call it C and so so the
model can also allow for sheer doneness
so we can allow Alice and Bob to answer
end MV according to some public
randomness but it won't change the value
of the game you can always fix the value
of the randomness to be some some best
value ok so this is the model ok so so
let's so these games are eyes at a lot
of places in theoretical computer
science so here is a famous example the
CHS such game ok so x and y are just
random bits uniformly random bits and we
require Alice and Bob to output bits a
and B such that the XOR of a and b is
equal to and of x and y so this is the
game and the value of the game is 0
point seven five so the best strategy
for them is just to output a equals 0
and B equals zero because they cannot
really predict the and locally so the
value of the game is point seven five
so they're two special classes of games
which are interesting TCS so one is the
projection game so a game is called a
projection game if for all X Y and a
there exists a unique be such that the
predicate is satisfied ok so it's a
projection the set of accepting answers
it's a unique game if the set of
accepting answers when it for any x and
y the set of accepting answers is a
permutation ok so for all X Y a there
exists a unique be and also for all X Y
be there exists a unique k such that the
predicate is satisfied so these are
these are just classes of games which
are interesting so now the question so
what is the parallel petition of a game
ok so now Alice and Bob are given
independent repetitions so independent x
1 to x and y 1 to y n X I Y I are
distributed according to mu iid and now
they require they require two output
answers a 1 2 a n and b1 to BN ok so now
each AI is a function of all of x1 to xn
h bi is a function of all x y 1 to y n
and they are required to win every copy
of the game so the win if the predicate
is satisfied for all X I via AI bi so
they have to win all every copy of the
game and the parallel petition question
is what is the relationship between
value of G to the n versus value of G to
the power n ok so that's the Pearl
repetition question so it's very similar
to the direct sum and the direct product
questions which gillip mentioned in the
previous stop so it's so it's quite
clear that value of G to the n is at
least value of G to the power n right
you can just play independently on all
the coordinates and you will win with
probability value of Z to the N ok so
that's that's quite clear and the more
interesting question is is the reverse
true can you do better than playing
independently ok and surprisingly you
can actually do better than playing the
game independently on all coordinates
there exists counter examples to there
exist examples where
true words can correlate the answers on
different coordinate and wind better
than value of Z to the N k with Polti
wet better who is sorry so this is Phi n
Verbitsky and this is progress so okay
so but still you can show non-trivial
theorems about value of Z to the N okay
so so so bits key was the first one to
prove that value of G to the N actually
go goes to 0 as n tends to infinity if
you start with some game which has value
less than 1k there were no explicit
bounds or the bounds of very bad because
then you use some combinatorial Hills
choose theorem but so Roz was the first
one to prove that there is actually an
exponentially exponential rate of decay
in n so if you start with the value
which is 1 minus epsilon epsilon is
small then value of Z to the N decays
like 1 minus epsilon to the 32 to the
Omega n over C so recall that C is the
answer length of the game so so 55 gain
verbitsky showed that actually the
dependence on the answer length is
almost optimal so they gave an example
of a game whose value is constant but
value of G to the end decays like some
constant to the N log C over C so if you
ignore this log see the valley the
dependence on answer length is all
almost optimal so then Colin stein in
2007 simplified Rises proof and improved
the parameters so he gave a parallel
petition in which value of G to the end
decays like 1 minus epsilon cube to the
N over C so this is for general games
and then Rao improved the bound for the
special class of projection games so if
the value of game is 1 minus epsilon
then value of G to the end decays like 1
minus epsilon square to the Omega so so
there to improvements so one the
exponent goes down from cube 2 square
and also there's no dependence on the
answer length
and then that all showed that this bound
is actually tight so he gave an example
of a unique game for which value of the
game is 11 is epsilon but you can
actually do much better than just
playing independently okay you can get
probability of winning 1 minus epsilon
square to the 0 of n so this actually
killed a very interesting approach to
the unique games conjecture so that this
square is very important okay so so why
is a wise by repetition interesting so
the most interesting application is the
PCP amplification so the PCP theorem
says that given so it can be set in this
manner so given a given a game it is
np-hard to decide if the value of the
game is won or if it's at most point 99
and so just by parallel repetition you
can actually amplify this gap so now
it's NP hard to decide if value of the
game is won or if it is at most Delta
for some any constant okay you can just
repeat this game log 1 over delta x then
you get this theorem for free and this
is the starting point for many optimal
and p hardness results in the literature
and so there are many other connections
of paragraph addition to the unique
games conjecture to the a of foams bell
inequality violations and etc so i won't
go into this connection so i will come
to the small value regime so if you look
at all these previous pal repetition
theorems they work in the regime when
the value of the game is close to one
okay so what if the value of the game to
start with is something very small which
is sub constant okay so they these
theorems still give you some decay which
is like to to the a to the minus n not
like Delta to the N soda new brand story
but the first ones to prove such a
theorem so if G is a projection game and
value of the game is Delta which is some
sub constant then value of G to the N
actually decays like Delta to the Omega
n this is the this is what you would
hope so this
so they use this to obtain optimal and P
hardness for approximating set cover so
you can approximate set cover within an
approximation ratio of log of N and
approximating it to within 1 minus
epsilon of log of n is np-hard so this
gives you that so this is for projection
games and so this was open for the so
the small value per repetition question
was open for general games and this is
the main theorem of the talk so we
proved that if G is any game and value
of J is Delta let Delta lies between
half and 1 over 2 to the sea macys
answer length of game then value of G to
the n is at most this viet quantity
Delta to the N log 1 over Delta or C so
you're off from perfect by repetition by
this factor of log 1 over Delta was C so
so this assumption Delta is at least one
or two to see is very natural because if
for all X Y there exists some winning a
and B some winning answers then the
players can randomly choose the answers
and win yes so does the example of eigen
beretsky also apply and oversee must be
any exponents here yes yes yes I don't
do that so yeah so that the bound is
tied actually up to constant factors so
you don't have an have this discrepancy
of law so this log 1 over Delta is
something that comes in the example yeah
and in the regime where Delta is smaller
than 1 over 2 to see you can buy a
simple reduction you can get this
theorem because the region where the
game is unwinnable it really tense
arises very nicely right when you can't
win the game just tense arises okay so
this is the theorem there is no direct
application of this result yet but it's
most more about the techniques so our
proof gives a very general framework for
propeller pitch in theorems and using
this framework you can recover all the
previous by repetition theorems of
colleen stein rao and dinner and store
so these proofs also work in the
high-value regime
for the production case you get rid of
see also yes yes and obviously no no you
just get here so you can also get the
projection game so you have to modify
the proof of it okay so this is the
theorem now let me talk about the the
proof overview so let us fix the
strategy for Z to the N okay so and I
will denote the event of winning in all
coordinates by w ok so what we want to
prove is if probability of W is too
large larger than the bound we want to
prove then you can use this strategy for
G to the N to design a
too-good-to-be-true strategy for G ok so
you can design a strategy for Jeep which
wins with probability greater than Delta
which is a contradiction so this is the
approach and the the most natural thing
to do is so you get your inputs X and Y
for a single copy of the game and you
embed these inputs into some random
coordinate I you sample rest of the
coordinates according to some
appropriate distribution and you run the
strategy for Z to the N and you output
whatever the strategy outputs on the is
coordinate ok so just embed your input
into a large strategy for Z to the N so
this is the strategy ok so so let us
look at the first thing one would try so
you set the input in the IH coordinate
to small X and small why these are
inputs you receive you sample the rest
of the coordinates according to mu just
iid k and then you answer according to
the annual then you run the strategy for
G to the N and answer whatever it
answers on the is coordinate ok so now
the problem with this strategy is that
probability of winning in this could be
very tiny right so we have no guarantee
on so the only guarantee we can give
this that since since you win on all the
coordinates with some tiny probability
you this strategy also winds of the
earth coordinate ok so the best bond we
can give on this is probability of W
which
which could be exponentially small than
what we want so so somehow we want to
zoom into this event w okay so you want
to move into a world where everything is
conditioned on w so in other words on
the i'th coordinate you receive the
inputs X and Y and you want to output
the answers a and B I conditioned on w
once you conditional w will you win with
probability 1 okay by definition and you
want to sample from this distribution
approximately so that is what you want
to do and one way to do this is the
following you set your inputs to ionath
coordinate to a small X and small why
you sample the rest of the coordinates
conditioned on small X small Y and W and
then you output whatever your strategy
outputs on the 8th coordinate so this
would this would this would achieve this
but the problem now is that we don't
know how to sample from this via
distribution so no one has knowledge
complete non knowledge of this
distribution because Alice only knows X
Bob only knows why so no one actually
knows this distribution you don't know
how to sample from this ok so that's the
main problem with this with this ok so
now so the real real approach is
something which interpolates this to ok
which luck so you again you set your
inputs to x and y now you don't actually
sample all the rest of the coordinates
there exists some random variable r i
will describe this explicitly you sample
that random variable are conditioned on
x y and w ok and you locally now Alice
and Bob output according to the answer
of the strategy condition on this random
variable and X and the BI condition are
and this Y so this is this this is the
actual strategy which works so for this
to work the properties of our that you
want are the following so you want that
the distribution of our condition on x y
and w should be approximately the same
as the distribution of our condition x +
w
approximately the same as distribution
of our condition y and w okay so that
Allison Bob individually have the
appropriate knowledge to actually sample
from this joint distribution this is the
least thing you want so this is a point
number one point number two is that our
should break the dependency between a
and B are right because here you out
putting something local for this
strategy to have some global sense this
should hold true it I should break the
dependency otherwise this does not make
any global sense the third point is that
our should break the dependency between
the event w and the random variables a
and B i right because so basically once
you'd sample the correct our condition w
you can forget about w or because the
distribution of AI bi and our condition
on w is the same as eib bi condition are
know W and product with our condition w
so once your sample our condition w can
forget about w so those are three
properties from our that you want and
then you will achieve that you actually
output from AI bi condition on w so the
way these properties are achieved are
using mutual information so we exhibit
an R which has these three properties so
the mutual information between R and X I
conditional why I and w is small the
mutual information between R and why I
condition X on w small by small I mean
much less than log 10 probability 0 w
which is the a priori bomb condition on
w creates log 1 our probability of w
bits of information and you want this
neutral informations to be much smaller
than that so this actually if you
interpret it it means exactly this the
second statement is something about the
structure of our its present in all the
previous peril repetition proves
basically breaking the dependency
between Alice's side and Bob side okay
so this is something standard the third
condition is saying that the mutual
information aibi and the indicator
random variable for the event w
condition on our X I and wire is small
by small i mean much smaller than the a
priori bond which is entropy of 1w so
these are the three conditions which
correspond to this
and once you exhibit an R that satisfy
satisfies these conditions you can
actually go through with the strategy
the only one additional tool you need is
are correlated sampling theorems I won't
go into these but basically they say
that if Alice and Bob both know some
approximations to the true distribution
then there is actually exists sampling
procedure which allows them to sample
approximately from the true distribution
so they are very various correlated
sampling theorems for various notions of
approximations you could have for
example for the high-value regime and
the low value regime you need to use
different correlated sampling theorem so
i won't go into this but also i will
show you the structure of our ok what r
is so before that let me take a detour
and know they have to be different I
mean they have to be different slightly
different
okay so okay so so before it's showing
with the structure of our let me that
and let me show you how conditioning can
help keep the mutual information low ok
so let m z1 to Zn be arbitrary
correlated random variables with the
entropy of em bounded by K which is much
less than n let's then the mutual
information between m and z12 ZN is at
most the entropy of em which is at most
K so now you would believe that if M has
very small compared to n information but
all of z12 ZN then the information m has
bought or typical zi is very small so
the and so the so what is the way to
formalize this intuition so we have this
so so mutual information m and zi may
not be typically small right because for
example you could have that all z 1 2 z
and M are equal to let us say a random
bit but this will be small with some
appropriate conditioning if you
conditioned on some subset of the Z is
okay so let me show you what the
appropriate conditioning is select small
s be a random number from 0 to n minus 1
let I be a random number from 1 to n
random index and let capital s be a
random subset of little s coordinates
from n minus I and if you condition if
you condition on zs the mutual
information m-man xia is actually small
so the expected mutual information
between m and zi condition on GS is at
most K over m so this is what you would
expect
so let us prove this it's a three line
proof so so so here is a different way
to view this distribution of I n capital
s you choose a random permutation pi of
12 n you again choose this step in the
same you choose small s to be random in
0 to n minus 1 and you said capital has
to be pipe this should be smallest you
said capital s should be PI 12 pious and
I to be pi s plus 1 so this is a this
distribution is identically identical to
the previous distribution but now you
can use the chain rule so expectation of
this mutual information is the mutual
information m n pi s plus 1 conditional
Z pi 1 2 pi s and then using the chain
rule this gives you what you need then
you can combine this using the chain
rule and then bound this by the entropy
of em so just using the chain rule this
gives you a very strong statement so so
keeping this in mind let's let's look at
the structure of our so this so this R
is inspired by the previous by
repetition proofs of roswell in stein
and rao and also by the proofs of the
direct product theorems in communication
complexity specifically this paper of
bremen draw weinstein and yahoo DF so so
we have these questions x 1 to x and y 1
to y n ok so the r will consists of some
questions from Alice's side and some
questions from Bob side and there will
be there will be an overlap in this
overlap we will also sample some of the
answers of the strategy for g 2 the end
will sample some a s & Bs and in this
overlap somewhere there will be I and
will exclude the questions from I this
is where you want to embed your inputs
so this is the structure of Arc some
questions from Le side some questions
from Bob side some answers
and the parameters have to be chosen
carefully the size of sides have to be
chosen carefully so the size of the set
so size of sight which contains Alice's
questions is a random number from three
and over 4 plus 1 to n the size of set
which contains box questions is a random
number again from three and over 4 plus
1 to N and the size set which contains
the answers is a random number from 1 to
t where t is some parameter you can
choose carefully so this is the
construction of our so so basically the
point of this R is to create multiple
symmetries so that various chain rules
work out okay so for example the fact
that we chose the size of set of X is to
be random allows you to argue that the
mutual information are in X I condition
y and w is small just by the chain rule
and you chose this you chose this
answers to be a random set this allows
you to prove that the correlation
between one W and the answers in the IH
coordinate is small because once you
condition on the answers you can now
apply the chain rule over the answers so
so that's the point of this art and
choosing this R is actually already 75
personas solution the rest twenty five
percent is I guess correlated sampling
and checking that these chain rules
actually work out yeah so that's so
that's all I say about the proof so to
list some open problems so so so one is
a paragraph petition for general
entangle games so entangle games are
games where I mean everything is the
same just that you allow the provers to
share some entanglement okay and in this
situation it's not known if the para
position actually holds or not the
special cases in which it is known for
example for projection games it's known
it's true by a work of de new store in
with it it's known for prior
distributions through a line of works by
jan press Lenny yow Sherlock's scarpa
and Chun boo and UN I guess we'll hear
about the last talk in this workshop so
this one question which is very
interesting another question is for
general classical games the best
palpation bound we have is 1 minus
epsilon cube to the N oversee and we
know that the exponent has to be square
by razzes example but it's not clear
whether two or three should be the
answer so that's an interesting problem
and the last one is a pair abrasion 43
plover games if you have 3 provides is a
bovine Charlie desperate position hold
and so this seems to a very hard
question also related to weather
information complexity can be made to
work in the multi-party communication
setting okay so okay I'll stop